CARTER MORGAN: This
week, we're talking
about encryption,
migrating legacy
workflows, and Kubernetes.
I'm Carter Morgan, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud," where
we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Cloud computing is
certainly the new standard.
But the complexity, cost,
and risk of a cloud migration
may be holding
your business back.
Bare Metal Solution is
designed to bridge this gap
by offering hardware
that supports enterprise
applications with a dedicated
connection to Google Cloud.
It's time for a cloud solution
that works for a specialized
legacy workloads.
As part of our non-stop
push for security,
we're updating the
external key manager,
which allows
businesses to maintain
separation between
their encrypted data
and the keys of that encryption.
We're also introducing
key access justifications
to provide a detailed
justification
each time an external
encryption key is requested.
With these two services,
you are the ultimate arbiter
of your data.
There's always more
work to be done.
And scaling that work
is a constant challenge.
But for Google
Kubernetes Engine,
we've begun the preview of
Batch, a Cloud native solution
for running batch workloads at
scale in an optimized manner.
Try it out and then let
us know what you think.
Seriously, the
product team wants
you to email them your
thoughts and questions.
And speaking of
Kubernetes, Cloud Code
is now generally available.
Developers can write,
debug, and deploy code
to Google Cloud or any
Kubernetes cluster.
And if you miss the features
of your preferred IDE,
there's an extension for that.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment or tweet us.
I'm Carter Morgan, and
we'll see you in the Cloud.